I love being anywhere near the water
especially during the summer I heard
from friends that Muskoka is Canada's
version of the Hamptons and I really
wanted to see it for myself the view
from my hotel was unreal there's all
these lakes and different waterways and
things that are all linked together and
different landscapes surrounding them
that you can see pretty much everywhere
you turn it's one of the most beautiful
areas in Canada with all the rocks the
islands fishing is pretty popular here
so I had a local guy take me out on his
boat highlight of that experience was
definitely catching a bass for the first
time poor calling the downtown area has
all of these amazing restaurants and
authentic shops where I've met my
friends after with Toronto being only
two hours away it has a really diverse
crowd I was really excited that my
fiance was able to meet me for the
weekend made it having her there to
experience it with me just made it that
much better
[Music]
Ontario is extremely close to home but
it's completely different than anything
we have in the States it's beautiful and
it feels miles away from a big city go
and wakeboarding on the lakes there made
me really feel like I was one of the
locals
if you just want to get away and have a
blast and thus coca is definitely the
place
[Music]
I would do this trip all over again in a
heartbeat
[Music]